and for the handful of people who come
out and say
guys this is wrong we need to look into
this
i'm going to object to some of these
votes i'm talking about guys like ted
cruz
josh hawley other people
what does the left say the left comes
out tries to ruin their careers
aoc i kid you not came out she's been
calling ted cruz and josh hawley
murderers
because she says she came out early on
and said that
nearly half the members of congress were
killed
in in the riot at the capitol of course
no member of congress was even injured
but
just they were all almost half of us
were killed and then she said yeah ted
cruz is trying to murder me
and now she's saying that guys like cruz
and hawley are
tantamount to rapists i'm a survivor of
sexual assault um
and i haven't told many people that in
my life when i
see a party
who cheered on violence
violence that killed five maybe now six
people a second capital police officer
took their life
in the aftermath of the attack
um this past week these people are just
trying to tell us
it's not a big deal and they're trying
to say
you're making too big a deal over it or
my favorite um this past
week ted cruz and now
representatives chip roy and oh by the
way some of the other representatives
who actually
encouraged people to threaten members of
congress or tweeted out the location of
the speaker
are now telling me to apologize for
saying and speaking truth
to what happened these are the tactics
of abusers
or rather these are the tactics that
abusers use
i don't know why she makes that
distinction because it means the same
thing so she's saying uh ted cruz
because he followed a constitutional
process and
uh voiced his objections to some of the
irregularities on the record
uh he's a murderer he tried to murder me
and uh
when cruz and hawley and some of these
other guys came out and said
okay apologize to us you can't call us
murderers
that's so wrong she says oh yeah you're
rapists too
she says i was i was sexually assaulted
i've never told anybody this but i was
sexually assaulted
and you are just like rapists
so i guess the firs the breaking news
here is that aoc says she was sexually
assaulted
uh the question you have to ask is is
that true
maybe maybe it was true i don't know if
if
people make that kind of a claim it's a
claim you want to take seriously
the trouble with aoc is that she's a
pathological liar
she's lied brazenly about not just
public policy in a way that even
politifact has given you know politifact
is a left-wing outlet
even they have given her uh some
difficult ratings because she's just
lied about i don't know defense spending
or
immigration enforcement she's lied about
the apocalypse saying the world's going
to end in 12 years
but but even more to the point here
she's lied about core
aspects of her biography that very few
people pointed out i actually i was one
of the few people that was able to point
this out
because i grew up in the town next to
aoc at
exactly the same time so aoc when she
was campaigning
pretended that she was raised in the
bronx she was not when she was very very
little she lived in the bronx but then
she grew up
in one of the wealthiest counties in the
country i know this because i lived in
the town right next door
and she lived in the town that was
wealthier than my town and she went to
very very good schools
and then for college she went to a very
expensive private school so she was
portraying herself as jenny from the
block
she got called out for it and she's
never given a good answer on that so
is this story that she's telling true or
not it could be but it's just
you can't take it as gospel truth when
somebody has a proven track record of
lying even about fundamental aspects
of her biography the other reason that
we have to be skeptical here is because
she's being so flippant
she's being so glib about what i think
is a serious issue
right rape is a pretty serious issue
guys
it's a about as serious as they get and
she
is using this i mean we've never heard
about before she's using it as just a
cudgel
to attack chip roy and ted cruz
she's saying you guys are like rapists
that's not the language of somebody who
takes that issue seriously so she won't
take it seriously i will take it
seriously
she'll trot it out for a cheap political
shot i i want to i want to take it much
more seriously i think than the left
does
because there is uh right now
a group of women who are accusing
marilyn manson
this uh you know pretty famous rock star
from the 90s and
i guess he's still pretty famous they're
they're accusing him of abuse
and this term sexual assault which has
only been popularized in recent decades
so it's broader than the term rape but
it does raise big questions about our
sort of
sexual environment about our legal
regime on this question
and on on what where where exactly
the the problems really begin because
the left has all the wrong answers on
this
uh but i think if we if we pursue the
issue a little bit
you'll you'll see where the seeds of
this kind of culture were planted
because in a way i can't believe i'm
saying this
in a way the left has a point they just
don't have the point they think
that they have i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the michael knowles show
to check out the full episode hit the
link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you